so in recent years the X-Men have become
a global power in Marvel Comics and in
fact there are mutants that now live on
Mars so for the non-comic reader this
can be incredibly confusing to try to
get into especially with fall of X
coming out a lot of people I think are
intrigued and trying to find a way into
the X-Men so we're going to make sense
of all this stuff in this video so the
way that Marvel handled the X-Men in
recent years it's kind of done in like
three phases so phase one was basically
the relaunch that was house and powers
of X and that focused on a woman named
Maura McTaggart so for decades in Marvel
Maura was just a mutant geneticist now
what Marvel did with house and powers of
X is they actually changed their
character up and they revealed that Mora
McTaggart actually has powers that
whenever she dies the timeline resets
now it doesn't reset the whole universe
back to its very Beginnings what it does
is it resets the timeline back to when
she was born so everything that took
place between the time that she was
conceived and the time she died it all
gets reset back to zero now of course
she had no idea this was her power until
the first time she died but when she
came back with her second life she
remembered everything from her first
life and that's the way her character
worked when she died the third time she
remembered everything from the first
life and the second life and that keeps
going on and on and on now more
McTaggart has died and reset the
timeline and been born again a total of
10 times and we're on the 10th life
right now this is what's going on in the
X-Men Comics the reason why this matters
is because over these different lives
that Maura McTaggart has had what she
did is she came to the realization
somewhere along the line a war will
always break out between the mutant
population and the human population and
no matter how this war transpires or
who's involved the mutant population
always gets destroyed and so what she
had been trying to do over the course of
these different lives was try to find a
way to ensure that the mutant population
came out on top in fact during one of
these lives she developed a cure for the
mutant Gene to basically eliminate it
from humanity and turn mutants into
normal humans ultimately she was killed
for her efforts and then the timeline
reset but the fact remains when you got
to the 10th life more McTaggart went to
visit Charles Xavier and when they first
met she allowed him to read her mind and
to see everything that she'd seen over
the course of the different lives that
she'd been living and that's when Xavier
realized we have to find a way to keep
Humanity from eradicating us at some
future point in time and so Xavier met
with Magneto and between Magneto Xavier
and more McTaggart they decided to
basically create their own island nation
and this is when they took up residence
on krakowa now once krakowa was chosen
to be the safe haven of the mutant
population Xavier Mora McTaggart and
Magneto did four things the first thing
they did is they opened the doors of
krakowa to every mutant across the world
whether they had traditionally been a
villain or a hero the fact was they were
all mutants so they were all United now
of course this would lead to rivalry
freeze it would lead to villains
fighting Heroes things along those lines
so to solve that problem the second
thing they did is they created the quiet
Council and a set of laws one of those
laws was that mutants could not harm
other mutants unless they be confined to
what was called the pit which was
basically just a giant hole in the
center of krakowa where you would remain
for eternity and in fact that was what
happened to Sabertooth for a Time the
third thing they did is they developed
technologies that could cure any mental
illness schizophrenia dementia
Alzheimer's as well as medicines that
could extend the lifespan of the average
person the only way these medicines
could be attained is if any one
particular country chose to recognize
the sovereignty of curcoa and then allow
all mutants from their country to leave
and travel to krakowa but the fourth
thing they did is they created what was
called Resurrection and what this
basically meant was that the mutant
population found a way to cheat death
that they had a group that was called
the five these were five different
mutants also known as Omega Level
mutants meaning they're some of the most
powerful mutants in existence but
between the five of them and the powers
they had they could do things like bring
Wolverine back from the dead and then
use their reality warping powers to
create adamantium and bonded to his
skeleton whenever a mutant was on
krakowa at all times their mind was
constantly being backed up to a database
so that if a mutant suddenly killed over
from a brain aneurysm they could be
resurrected and all the memories they
had up until the moment they died would
be put back in their head what's funny
about this is the resurrection protocols
actually became a major focus of an
event called Judgment Day which was a
war between the Avengers the X-Men and
the eternals but that's why they're here
nor there now this takes us into what's
basically the second phase of the X-Men
era and this was the era of krakowa
oracco and okara these three things
genuinely confuse people so I will make
it all make sense what Marvel tells us
is that at some point in the distant
past of Earth running up to about five
to ten thousand years ago there was a
giant land mass that was called okara
now the reason why I say five to ten
thousand years ago is because during
that time period apocalypse one of the
oldest mutants in existence alongside
his wife Genesis had basically turned
okara into a giant Safe Haven where all
mutants resided the kicker about all
this is that about five to ten thousand
years ago someone used the Twilight
sword of certain and cut a hole cut a
literal Rift in the very fabric of
reality at okara which allowed all these
different demonic beings From Another
Dimension to come pouring into Earth and
so apocalypse and his wife Genesis
rallied all the mutants across the world
at that point in time and launched an
attack to try to counter the invading
forces but during this war one
apocalypse and his wife started to
realize is the only way for this
conflict to end was for someone or a
group of people to go to the other side
of the rift and to seal it shut and
that's what apocalypse's wife Jenna
services and most mutants on Earth at
that time did and so apocalypse was
really the only mutant left on Earth
there were a few but for the most part
he was the only one now when the forces
of Genesis transitioned from Earth into
this other dimension and they sealed the
breach it cut okara in half the half of
okara that stayed on Earth became
krakowa the other half that stayed in
the dimension was renamed to arako now
the reason why all of this is so
important and why we're even covering it
is because during the time in which
Genesis and her forces were confined to
arako they were basically waging a
never-ending war against these demonic
forces and so that meant the life they
knew was just war and Chaos now the
benefit of this is they constantly grew
more powerful and that's why the mutants
within arako were so incredibly powerful
in comparison to the mutants on earth
now during the events of ten of Swords
it was a great big huge tournament more
or less but mutants from Morocco were
brought to Earth and then a giant event
in suit at the end of that the breach
was temporarily unsealed and those
mutants from Morocco who wanted to leave
and come to Earth were allowed to do so
once that decision had been made and
once all the mutants who wanted to leave
Morocco did leave Morocco the breach was
resealed again now the biggest problem
you had here is that most all mutants
who lived in krakowa were essentially
peaceful they didn't really Chase
conflict in war if they didn't have to
but the mutants from Morocco knew
nothing but war and so that meant that
these two groups could not coexist so
what ended up happening is that the
mutants from Morocco who initially went
to cocoa left and they basically took up
residence on Mars and then renamed Mars
to new oracco or just arako so that's
why you have mutants on Mars right now
now the big thing that came out of like
the third phase was the revelation of
Maura McTaggart that where she had
initially met with Xavier and initially
met with Magneto and pitched herself as
this person that was just trying to find
a way to save the new the population
what she was trying to do was eliminate
the mutant population because over the
course of her lives she'd come to the
realization there was no way for the
mutant population to win nothing that
could be done would save the mutant
population from complete and utter
destruction the only way to get around
that was by virtue of basically
inventing the resurrection process and
that what would happen over however many
years before that event took place is
that if one thousand mutants died over
the course of a year one thousand
mutants would be resurrected but one of
those mutants would be resurrected
without their powers but because only
mutants are allowed on the nation of
krakowa that mutant that came back with
no powers would be sent away and that
was the goal of Mora McTaggart to slowly
eliminate the mutant Gene over time as
different mutants were being resurrected
and basically reduce the number of
mutants on Earth turning all those
different mutants into humans the war
between the mutant population and the
human population cannot take place if
there are no mutants that took place in
a story called Inferno and that
basically brought an end to the Run of
Jonathan Hickman truth to tell ever
since then Marvel's just kind of been
killing time so having said all that if
you guys are wanting to get caught up
with everything related to the X-Men
including the things that we did talk
about here as well as the things that we
didn't make sure you click this link to
our X-Men playlist it'll have everything
that you want to know if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you hit the
like button and make sure you subscribe
to become part of the channel and I will
catch you all later
peace